There are lots of ways you may find this.
One is to look at the output from dir and see all the methods available for sets
and one thing you might notice looking at this is that
there are methods like difference followed by difference_update
Similarly for intersection, intersection_update.
Similarly for symmetric difference, symmetric difference_update
and then we get to union, there is no union_update, but the method following union is called update.
So that sounds like a good one to try.
It is certainly not enough to know that it does what we want, but let's try it.
So we make a new set t and then let's try updating s with t.
Now, we could've actually look at this documentation.
It says update the set with union of itself and others
that might give us a good guess that it's going to do what we want already,
but let's actually try it and now let's see what's in s.
Well, we started with a set 1, 2, 3.
We union it with this set that should add elements for 4, 6, and 7 to the set.
Let's check the t was not modified and indeed, it was not.
Although, you might notice that the order of the elements is different
from what they were when we created t from this list,
but remember that what a set is an unordered collection of elements.
So the order that it prints out here does not mean anything.
It's the same set as the one listed in this order.
We could try that confirming that with an equality test and indeed, these two sets are equal.
So this experiment gives us some confidence that update, that's what we want.